голова президентської фракції Юрій
Луценка я головним претендентом на крісло
генпрокурором для нього за значення може
пробувати зради ти законністю проценко
без прокурорську дочку в dota юра дачного
квіти та сміх врахував це відомством реакції
на ціни однозначно а за ногу боці сама
живи собі дня ти по саду люди не за
нім вона зі старої системи прокуратури
абетку закони писані під конкретний
заклик
я була в управлінні центру тощо. і
корупції Віталій Шабунін Вісту та
проведення про за роги публічного
конкурсу серед юристів на посаду крим
прокурором України закон дресирований
потрібні
за словами шабуніна перша та найважливіший
тест мої будні hawaiian прокурора
радикально чистка у відомстві для мене
було показу кабана просто промови що
зайди на той центр і петляти сік на
посадок чується за ми шоці на ніке
провал чи реформа генпрокуратури
які друк майдану бали в системі та
хіт кого закриттям законності в
кримінальних інших мВС зараз майдану
які особливі ставало праворуч підкури
іванющенко та частини трьох людей підвищується
на посаду я гарантую ще жадібних
позитивних зрушень він і буде
головна проблема в тому ще можна владі
в Україні не хочу замінити і свою смичку
і сюди в будинку бізнесу та політики
поважають за kidney експерти їжу дають
влада на мага eset remote контроль над
прокуратуру за місця ви щоб її реформа
вати ланцюга тверджу та зачату панночку
зайвих вікон прокурора віктора шоку на
Давид сакварелідзе це як 1
політика саме політика я до вузла
джина з найвищим перед обличчям ми не дуже
важко повірять ще сьогодні прокуратура
заступника генерального прокурора та як
завтра реально буду змінила ти новий
прокурор
ділками in озвучити свої ідеї якщо
майданівці вже будуть 4 генпрокурори
практика так і не змінилося
гроза старим та провалу ми виробляли
шедоу радикалізації істоти вражають
експерти antique у риб тіні протести
спить підлоги машин живе був ти на ще
давно у ківі